it happens every year the leaves change
the animals take in the fresh crisp air
and the apples ripen yep
them apples except this year picking
apples has never been harder at least
for some of us
alright alright okay that's a finger
just look at this lineup there's the new
iPhone 10 are starting at $750 the new
iPhone 10's starting at $1000 and the
iPhone 10's max at $1,100 all three have
similar all screen designs face ID and
fast 812 Bionic processors inside the
main difference besides size and price
the 10r has some camera and screen
compromises even more confusing those
old apples the iPhone 7 and 8 are still
available yeah no one wants an old Apple
although they do start at $450
luckily me and my team of experts here
have been testing all the phones
especially the iPhone 10 R which really
is the Apple sweet spot you guys ready
to review
[Music]
okay let's start with the camera in this
fabulous smelling animal pen
unlike the two camera system on the back
of the 10s and the 10s max the 10 R only
has one wide-angle camera the single
camera still takes wonderful shots but
does mean sacrificing some tricks first
because there's no telephoto camera to
zoom in on scenes you've got to get
closer to your subjects which means in
this case scaring them away the 10r does
have portrait mode that's the feature
that adds blur around a subject to make
it look more professional but instead of
using a second camera to figure out
where to blur it uses software it works
okay on faces though as you can see here
the one taken on the 10r looks a little
more fake on the other hand it works
even better than the 10s in low light
because it's just applying the effect to
the wide-angle shot but here's the crazy
part my New Farm friends it doesn't work
on animals
it looks specifically for human faces
and there's even an alert that says no
person detected so if taking portrait
shots of your pet donkey baby goat or
cow is important to you the 10 s is your
answer although if you use the selfie
camera which also enables facial
recognition portrait mode works on all
kinds of critters
[Music]
the screen is the other main difference
between the 10 s and the 10 are the 5
point 8 inch 10 s and the 6.5 inch 10 s
max have OLED screens and the 6.1 inch
10 R has an LCD screen like older
iPhones you probably can't tell in this
video but on the 10s is screen there's
more contrast and everything looks a bit
crisper
but the difference isn't super dramatic
really you can only tell the difference
when you hold them side-by-side a more
noticeable difference the 10 R has this
slightly annoying bigger bezel I do find
the 6.1 inch screen a tad big for my
smaller hand and I wish Apple use the
extra space better with added software
features that said I really do prefer
the colourful design of the 10r
in addition to this apple red it comes
in five other colors there's one place
where the 10r knocks down the 10's
battery life and what better way to
explain battery life than with apple
cider donuts because of its lower
resolution screen in everyday use the 10
hours battery lasted one to two hours
longer than the 10 s and the 10 s max a
my video streaming test the 10 s lasted
10 and a half hours while the 10 are in
the 10 s max lasted nearly 13 hours oh
yeah the 10 are like the 10 s is
resistant to everyday spills like hard
cider
so which Apple do you pick if that
better screen and camera is a must-have
go 10s or 10s max but honestly if you
just want to save money and get a damn
good iPhone with longer battery life the
cheaper 10 R is the one to pluck from
the tree
not a real one it's not a real Apple
it's it's an apple with an uppercase a
you